[Music]  uh  ronnie what do we got we got units  headed out there now you're missing fire  everybody i think i'll buy walkers  it's okay  oh my god  it's okay it's okay we're okay we're  okay  okay mom  oh my god  [Music]  friend  oh  [Applause]  what is going on  it's very exciting to be able to come  back to the theaters to see a quiet  place too because  it was always designed for a theatrical  experience  it's such an inspired sequel the world  expands in this one because they have to  venture out  the second movie is much bigger it's a  much scarier movie  it's a horror movie you want to watch it  in the dark  jump and leap and gasp together  i'm really excited for you guys to see  it  you